[Applause]
six years ago I discovered something
that scientists have been wanting to
know for years how do you capture the
attention of a roomful of extremely
bored teenagers it turns out all you
have to do is mention the word
pornography let me tell you how I first
learned this in 2012 I was sitting in a
crowded room full of high school
students who were attending an
after-school program in Boston and my
job as guest speaker for the day was to
inspire them to think about how exciting
it would be to have a career in public
health the problem was as I looked at
their faces I could see that their eyes
were glazing over and they were just
tuning out it didn't even matter that I
wore what I thought was my cool outfit
that day yeah I was just losing my
audience so then one of the two adults
who worked for the program said aren't
you doing some research about
pornography
maybe tell them about that all of a
sudden that roomful of high school
students exploded into laughter
high fives I think there were some loud
hooting noises and all anyone had done
is say that one word pornography that
moment would prove to be an important
turning point for me in my professional
mission of finding solutions to end
dating and sexual violence at that point
I've been working for more than a decade
on the seemingly intractable problem of
dating violence data from the US Centers
for Disease Control and Prevention
demonstrate that one in five high school
attending youth experience physical
and/or sexual abuse by a dating partner
each year in the u.s. that makes dating
violence more prevalent than being
bullied on school property seriously
considering suicide or even vaping in
that same population but solutions were
proving elusive
and I was working with a research team
that was hunting for novel answers to
the question what's causing dating abuse
and how do we stop it one of the
research studies that we were working on
at the time
happened to include a few questions
about pornography and something
unexpected was emerging from our
findings eleven percent of the teen
girls in our sample reported that they
had been forced or threatened to do
sexual things that the perpetrator saw
in pornography that got me curious was
pornography to blame for any percentage
of dating violence or was it more like a
coincidence that the pornography users
also happen to be more unlikely to be in
unhealthy relationships I investigated
by reading everything that I could from
the peer-reviewed literature and by
conducting my own research I wanted to
know what kinds of sexually explicit
media youth were watching and how often
and why and see if I could piece
together if it was part of the reason
that for so many of them dating
relationships were apparently unhealthy
as I read I tried to keep an open mind
even though there were plenty of members
of the public who already made up their
mind about the issue why would I keep an
open mind about pornography well I'm a
trained social scientist so it's my job
to be objective but I know most of what
people call sex positive that means that
I fully support people's right to enjoy
whatever kind of sex life and sexuality
they find fulfilling no matter what it
involves as long as it includes the
enthusiastic consent of all parties
involved
that said I personally wasn't inclined
towards watching pornography
I'd seen some didn't really do anything
for me and as a mom of two soon-to-be
teenage children I had my own concerns
about what seeing pornography could do
to them
I noticed that while there were a lot of
people who were denouncing pornography
there were also people who were staunch
defenders of it for a variety of reasons
so in my scholarly exploration I
genuinely tried to under
stand was pornography bad for you or was
it good for you wasn't misogynist or was
it empowering and there was not one
singular answer that emerged clearly
there was one longitudinal study that
had me really worried that showed that
teenagers who saw pornography were
subsequently more likely to perpetrate
sexual violence but the design of the
study didn't allow for definitive causal
conclusions and there were other studies
that did not find that adolescent
pornography use was associated with
certain negative outcomes even though
there were other studies that did find
that but as I spoke to other experts
I felt tremendous pressure to pick a
side about pornography join one team or
the other I was even told that it was
weak minded of me not to be able to pick
out the one correct answer about
pornography and it was complicated
because there is an industry that is
capitalizing off of audience's
fascination with seeing women in
particular not just having sex but being
choked gagged slapped spit upon a jack
elated upon called degrading names over
and over during sex and not always
clearly with their consent most people
would agree that we have a serious
problem with misogyny sexual violence
and rape in this country and pornography
probably isn't helping with any of that
and a critically important problem to me
was that for more than a century the
anti-pornography position had been used
as a pretext for discriminating against
gays and lesbians or people who have
kinks or have fetishes so I could see
why on the one hand we might be very
worried about the messages that
pornography is sending and on the other
hand why we might be really worried
about going overboard indicted it for
the next two years I've looked into
every scary horrifying claim that I
could find about the average age at
which people first
pornography or what it does to their
brains or their sexuality here's what I
have to report back the free online
mainstream pornography that's the kind
that teenagers are most likely to see is
a completely terrible form of sex
education but that's not what it was
intended for and it probably is not
instantly poisoning their minds or
turning them into compulsive users the
way that some ideologues would have you
believe it's a rare person who doesn't
see some pornography in their youth by
the time they're 18 years old 93% of
first year college males and 62% of
females have seen pornography at least
once and though people like to say that
the Internet has made pornography
ubiquitous or basically guarantees that
any young child who's handed a
smartphone is definitely gonna see
pornography data don't really support
that a nationally representative study
found that in the year 2016 percent of
10 to 13 year old youth reported that
they've seen pornography in the past
year and by 2010 that figure had
increased but only to 30 percent so it
wasn't everybody our problems with
adolescents and sexual violence
perpetration is not only because of
pornography in fact a recent study found
that adolescents are more likely to see
sexualized images in other kinds of
media besides pornography think about
all those sexualized video games or TV
shows or music videos and it could be
exposure to a steady stream of violent
media that instead of or in addition to
the sexualized images is causing our
problems by focusing on the potential
harms of pornography alone we may be
distracting ourselves from bigger issues
or missing root
causes of dating and sexual violence
which are the true public health crises
that said even my own research
demonstrates that adolescents are
turning to pornography for education and
information about sex and that's because
they can't find reliable and factual
information elsewhere less than 50
percent of the states in the United
States require that sex education be
taught in schools including how to
prevent coerced sex and less than half
of those states require that the
information presented be medically
accurate so in that Boston after-school
program those kids really wanted to talk
about sex and they really wanted to talk
about pornography and they wanted to
talk about those things a whole lot more
than they wanted to talk about dating or
sexual violence so we realized we could
cover all of the same topics that we
might normally talk about under the
guise of healthy relationships education
like what's the definition of sexual
consent or how do you know if you're
hurting somebody during sex or what are
healthy boundaries to have when you're
flirting all of these same things we
could discuss by using pornography as
the jumping-off point for our
conversation it's sort of like when
adults give kids that dessert like
brownies but they secretly baked a
zucchini or something healthy inside of
it we could talk to the kids about the
healthy stuff the stuff that's good for
you but hide it inside a conversation
that was about something that they
thought they wanted to be talking about
we also discovered something that we
didn't necessarily set out to find which
is that there's a fantastic way to have
a conversation with teenagers about
pornography and that is keep the
conversation true to science admit what
we know and what we don't know about the
impact of pornography talk about where
there are mixed results or where there
are weaknesses in the studies that have
been conducted invite the adolescents to
become critical consumers of the
research literature on pornography
as well as the pornography itself that
really fits with adolescent development
adolescents like to question things and
they like to be invited to think for
themselves then we realized by starting
to experiment teaching some classes and
consent respect in pornography that
trying to scare adolescents into a
particular point of view or jam a
one-sided argument down their throat
about pornography not only probably does
not work but really doesn't model the
kind of respectful consensual behavior
that we want them to learn so our
approach what we call pornography
literacy is about presenting the truth
about pornography to the best of our
knowledge given that there is an
ever-changing evidence base when people
hear that we teach a 9:00 session 18
hour class in pornography literacy to
teenagers I think that they either think
that we're sitting kids down and trying
to show them how to watch pornography
which is not what we do or that were
part of an anti pornography activist
group that's trying to convince them
that if they ever saw pornography it
would be the number one worst thing for
their health ever and that's not it
either
our secret ingredient is that we're
non-judgmental we don't think that youth
should be watching pornography but above
all we want them to become critical
thinkers if and when they do see it and
we've learned from the number of
requests for our curriculum and our
training from across the u.s. and beyond
that there are a lot of parents and a
lot of teachers who really do want to be
having these more nuanced and realistic
conversations with teenagers about
pornography we've had requests from Utah
to Vermont to Alabama to Hawaii so in
that after-school program what I saw is
that from the minute we mentioned the
word pornography those kids were ready
to jump into a back and forth about what
they did and didn't want to see in
pornography and what they didn't didn't
want to do during sex and what was
degrading to women or unfair to men or
racist all of it and they made some
really sophisticated points exactly the
kinds of things that we would want them
to be talking about as a violence
prevention activist and as teachers we
might leave the class one day and think
it is really sad that there's that one
boy in our class who thinks that all
women have orgasms from anal sex and we
might leave class the next week and
think I'm really glad that there's that
one kid in our class who's gay who said
that seeing his sexuality represented in
pornography saved his life or there's
that one girl in our class who said that
she's feeling a lot better about her
body because she saw someone shaped like
her as the object of desire in some tame
pornography so this is where I find
myself as a violence prevention activist
I find myself talking about and
researching pornography and though it
would be easier things in life were all
one way or the other what I've found in
my conversations with teenagers about
pornography is that they remain engaged
in these conversations because we allow
them to grapple with the complexities
and because we're honest about the
science these adolescents may not be
adults yet but they are living in an
adult world and they're ready for adult
conversations thank you
[Applause]